alright here we go y'all let's go live
tender to digital attended unattended
okay all right y'all we don't do this -
turn turn turn turn
senator
- to the turn
[Music]
I just want to enjoy the music for a
second
[Music]
kids alive how come I can't see it on my
down page man it's like just damn game
dude all right you guys could see me
though right
hey everybody hey welcome to Griffin
gaming
girlfriend gaming fatality reactions
alright so I'm gonna go to the learn
okay and then I'm gonna do oh [ __ ] okay
here we go
fatality fatalities alright we're gonna
learn how to do all these right because
just go we're gonna do each one and we
can see what their fatalities are let's
do this tennis is intended to oh who's
she fight I'll he'll fight the next
person oh wait okay let's have him fight
we'll have him fight the last person at
the end of they'll fight okay here we go
and I'll go to each and we go to each
one of these two Special Forces desert
commands okay alright let's do this [ __ ]
umm alright how do you do it
finish her okay left left no right left
downtown beat oh here we go oh [ __ ] oh
oh oh that's [ __ ] up that's not even
right that's not even right oh my god oh
and then somebody do a tomato adder so
that's nasty
oh that's nasty and [ __ ] up oh my god
that's nasty you [ __ ] up
oh the tomato is just like that's not
necessary the tomato is not necessary
you know what I mean okay so now we got
Johnny okay so now we go to Sonia and
then she will beat up Johnny case for
what he just did oh my god
this is unnecessary okay we went to wait
where we were we we went to Special
Forces now we're gonna go to black
market alley more good there you go oh
my god the tomato was just on this the
tomato was unnecessary like you know
what I mean he's already kept up it and
then the tomato comes goddamn dude
alright finish him right down left nope
down right left why oh look at me Oh air
support oh oh oh no oh no not the blades
not the blade oh no [ __ ]
it's a blade it's gonna be the blade oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
this oh my god
[Music]
oh my god this is just not nice just
came a nice y'all okay so now we're
gonna do Cassie cage and she is gonna
fight Sonya for what she just did Sam
yeah Sonya has to pay for what she just
did and then we go to CyberLink with a
similar sniper didn't quit assembly are
you some ice taxi
okay here we go Furniture down down left
B that's easy
down down left be Oh Oh see you kick in
the chest you'll kick this bitch's heart
out oh no oh that's [ __ ] up
that's not nice right that's not even
right it'll make a heart where her heart
was oh my god this [ __ ] ain't right you
ain't right girl you ain't right Cassie
cage Cascade ain't right
oh wow thought that was meanness just
this [ __ ] is this shiz
ill okay alright black new time Jack's
big and you know what you need to go
beat up this white girl for what she
just did
he need to go beat up this white girl
for what she just did y'all talk cotton
war-camp why does he talk like this okay
here we go
[Music]
- - halt okay
right down right a way lately okay here
we go all right hold on hold on
yes oh [ __ ] put something on her back yo
you put something on her back
oh he cut the [ __ ] in half oh my god
they're all cooked
she got cooked intestines y'all oh my
god
he made chitlins he made chitlins with
her he made chitlins oh [ __ ] this is oh
[Applause]
my god oh my god you can't make chitlins
with a white girl I survived you think
you can't survive that people have to
come back for that okay let's go
scorpions school pin but do they have
more than one sink
no no I don't want it to be scorpion no
Jack's got two jacks got to suffer for
what he has done all right where were we
tarkanian war camp shanked tents ooh
island ruins what set it right Jackson's
island ruins oh you did they did all
right here we go finish him
okay left damn down X oh well you got to
be in this
Oh fire oh we can oh no he's still alive
he's the what cut his head off oh my
gosh oh that's not right that's not
necessary oh my gosh school that's not
right doubt that that whole thing wasn't
right
oh look at this head just float in there
like that oh my god this [ __ ] is nasty
y'all this is mad nasty okay oh and
thanks for the dollar whoever sent me
that dollar I appreciate it
don't be bashful y'all okay so that was
scorpion so we're gonna go to noob noob
noob saibot wait what is this [ __ ] okay
noob saibot noob saibot
okay and then and then scorpion has to
die for beating up the black dude like
that black dragon fight club here we go
y'all here we go y'all share my video
let's get people going we got to get a
hundred likes on this [ __ ] so can go
viral on YouTube
sure sure okay
left right left right bean oh I got that
damn look at my little button control
let's see what hello oh no oh for the
portal open the portal oh my god you
pulled apart
and it is sad steam oh my god hey no new
you let him know I don't know ain't no
new Sun ain't no new oh this is this is
nasty just nasty this is nasty y'all
Muraki
yes at it right my rocket needs to hit
up new new cybot needs to suffer for
what he just did
okay dragon flight club okay come the
Coliseum beast pin pull the seal beast I
guess they don't have sees in this world
here we go y'all
here we go don't be bashful with that
super chat through - erm okay left down
left why no are you doing the right
without down that boy yeah okay
oh you pull off his face goddamnit
oh you pulled up Oh more of his face oh
no oh [ __ ] oh the guy was still alive oh
wow oh my god that's just nasty man this
is nasty y'all [ __ ] is nasty
okay here we go
okay bye who's that Baraka okay raiden
raiden raiden is to be doubly Baraka for
[ __ ] eating a dude's brain are they
right all right where were we
uh dragon had calcium be spent Goro's
lair yeah yeah he did make that brain
look like mmm give me some of that brain
finish him
okay left hour left X oh [ __ ] I didn't
do it right no got a do it again alright
we try didn't do it right
Oh ray there's gonna be some kind of
like magic [ __ ] Pig Oh magic - [ __ ] out
of this dude alright
confirm let's do this again I gotta get
it right when the ones that are up close
those ones are hard those are the hard
ones okay
okay here we go - okay left down left X
okay left down left I know left down no
god dammit man oh we got juice
we got to do this one again we got to do
this again till we get it right we gonna
do it till we get it right you know what
I mean
I don't think rains even that good this
was not that good it's so annoying oh my
god I'll keep messing this one up guys I
keep messing this one up here we go okay
left down left X Oh what okay let's see
how long this takes
oh I should go slow huh you think so I
just see all right here we go are you
right oh no oh no oh that one wasn't
that bad how brutal is this game that
this guy just rips off these guys arms
and legs put him into a ball and blew
him up and I'm like that was okay that's
like a slap in the face in this game
Uranus wasn't that good good all right
here we go raid in okay
oh wait is she married to this guy are
they married
wait is Jacque who has married they must
be married or a brother and sister you
know what we night we gonna have I might
have them fight each other
jerks Jax is coming back he got caught
cheating goal art wait let me see
Colosseum be spin where am I go Lars
there yeah I don't hear bull she wool
she okay so we're gonna had a but I do
the black woman beat up the black dude
oh this is her oh it's her father
oh my gosh you got daddy issues she got
daddy issues okay right left wait right
left right a no no let's get it right oh
no oh [ __ ] no oh god damn oh no oh man
you know what
you should have went to her piano
recital should have went to her piano
recital bro oh that was that was brutal
that was brutal
okay let's see sub-zero soap zoo and
then he's gonna be that sick little beat
up Jackie you don't you don't treat your
father like that Jackie so you have to
be punished wushu we went to that one
shin ox bone tempo songs boom yes I read
Mortal Kombat ease
okay here we go finish her
left-right-left why ah let's eat okay
okay okay oh yeah I always go cut her
head off you don't cut her head off
oh oh why oh no that's so much all the
time
oh that's someone's necessary oh man
sub-zero ain't [ __ ] around dude oh
[Applause]
man house that's brutal wait wait why
don't do this again
oh yeah I messed up let's do it again
anyway uh uh we got that one twice by
accident
Oh chopped her head off uh that's not
necessary your Chi did do she did why
flawless victory we got that one again
it cuz I didn't do it right okay
confirm oh they have oh I didn't know
there was their second fatalities for
the people oh I didn't even know that
okay where do you see that okay if you
select oh wait oh no I didn't even know
there was other fatalities oh wow oh no
oh we're gonna have to go back oh man we
got to
oh wow okay I got to do this one again
we got to do Sub Zero again let's have
him beat up the dad you go beat up the
whole family okay I didn't realize it
has second fatalities oh wow [ __ ] we'd
have to go back and do all of them oh no
okay here we go
pretty sure okay left right left white
okay uh
oh this is the same one I thought man
that's the same one [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
sub-zero through all this victory
[Applause]
alright we just go through all of them
though we don't I can't I didn't realize
that will stop I'm from this point on
I'll do to do them twice okay will do
they're both okay so alright so you
press wait how do you get to the is that
it oh there we go
so that's the bro brutal one oh okay
that's so soon okay I didn't know that
try shouting trap dungeon sounds like a
rap song shelley trap dungeon okay
finish him all right left down down ex
oh oh oh no oh oh I'll always go dance
with him he dancing with him dancing
with them this is nasty okay
[Music]
okay so that's wait wait wait wait okay
so
okay is this one different rotten
scoundrel or gonna see if I could do
that without alright Sub Zero Sub Zero
needs to get it some zero needs to get
it y'all how can this eat this is a
different okay here we go
this might be the same thing I don't
know if I could do it okay left no no
yes the same okay I don't know how to
pick the other fatalities yes the same
one
[Music]
yeah I don't know how to pick the second
thing maybe
yeah the smash that like button y'all
smash that like button there's a hundred
of you in here smash that like button
help a brother out okay all right I
don't know how to get to the other
fatalities so I'm just gonna keep going
like this it's right there you just hit
it okay let's go to COBOL COBOL see I
don't understand okay whatever
alright so cabal's got wait cabal needs
to beat up Kay know what he did yeah I
don't know how to do two other
fatalities I don't think if you'll
practice the other fatalities maybe it's
the only one right now it's closed then
you open them up as you play then you
get to practice I don't know
all right here we go finisher all right
left okay left right down left a oh no
way do it again yeah oh oh no Oh si ball
came out oh [ __ ] his eye ball came out
[Music]
that was the nastiest one oh my god oh
[Applause]
that's nasty
oh my god oh that's so nasty oh my god
hello everybody in the chat I can see
you guys but I'm just focusing on this
that one wasn't it that's the bet yet I
agree that's the best one cabal wait
okay so if I pick cabal again Brian
so that was CI I'd like to think that
though I switched to it right but it's
the same one
shoes variation oh there's a variation
no let's just keep going okay yeah Luque
is gonna be the Cabal for what he just
did he needs to suffer for what he just
did see of blood see you blood oh my God
he's a nasty oh this is nasty
okay here we go finish him okay down
left down right X down left down right X
okay wait we got to get in here
down left down right X oh look at that
button work son okay [ __ ] him up
ow ouch ouch oh [ __ ] that one was
alright that was just alright no I'm not
okay slight new fighter do King looks
cool but that wasn't necessary that's
brutal as some of these other ones right
mu cang ok katana katana is she gonna
beat up okay wait
see I don't know let's see she gonna
beat up Lu Kang you need to get beat up
Lu for what you just what you done did
what you done did Lu wait where were we
just at sea a blood see a blood should I
write you
well that was his second fatality all
right here we go
[Music]
okay down down down why that was easy oh
oh no oh no oh oh I'm she taking out all
his guts
oh wow that's nasty relationship goals
that's hilarious
yeah I got a unlock [ __ ] first okay
let's go to Coombe Lao Loum Lao he's
gonna beat up katana she needs to suffer
for what she just did girl tick garage
bunker pick one is it a tank is it a
garage or is it a bunker
[Music]
finish her okay down left okay down left
okay wait I just
[Music]
Oh you chopped it oh [ __ ] man Oh Oh wine
look the titties are all far apart
titties are way over here that one was
brutal okay
here we go cool Lao Jade Jade needs to
beat up cool Lao for but you don't
deserve to live what you've done so
little trouble Shaolin trap dungeon
sound good like a rap genre finish em
all right down down left down beat oh
look at me get the button oh [ __ ] oh oh
that's [ __ ] up
oh no deal
that's brutal oh look at his mouth is
all open god damn dude that sucks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god this is nasty this game it's
nasty who was that
wait Kung Lao no no that dubs Jade okay
so now we got to go to Scarlett Scarlett
it's gonna [ __ ] up jay-z we're almost
done with all these places to trap
dungeon love lost time over there farms
of the cartoon okay here we go y'all
whoo god this is brutal now I'm having
nightmares over this [ __ ] man wait wait
nope nope boom boom boom boom that's he
walking into your kid is watching this
oh no you're gonna check out all our
blood and they kill her with it oh no
ouch ouch
oh oh oh I oh man oh I bawled eyeballs
Holmes's eyeball
[Music]
popsicle blood popsicle oh god oh man
this [ __ ] is brutal this [ __ ] has brewed
Oh and it's nasty y'all and it's nasty
oh my god it's just nasty
okay so who was that that was Scarlett
so Aaron black yeah needs to scarless
going to suffer for what she has done
car rod ship okay here we go
finish her down down down X oh he's got
a potion Oh acid
oh oh that's [ __ ] up oh no you gonna
put her he gonna put her head in it he
gonna put her oh no oh [ __ ] what our oh
that one was nasty
oh that one was nasty oh my god that was
nasty
oh my god you [ __ ] her up dude okay
Devorah Devorah devorah nice ooh there
yeah Aaron black be secret punished I
mean I start over now power okay here we
go to see what devorah's got let's see
what devorah's got
[Music]
Dana sham
okay let's see huh uh oh look at me get
that button work oh that's gotta hurt Oh
Oh vomited in his mouth what's happening
what's happening oh [ __ ] oh no oh my
gosh she told she transformed it into a
spider oh that's nasty
I'll look at this head look at the brain
is still floating in the air
oh that's God the graphics on this is
just disgusting man oh my god you just
vomited on her on his face Kotal Kahn
all you need to get the spider [ __ ] to
Bora Bora
Cybermen yes you cleaned up and still
hit it
that's how late to chat is from you guys
here we go left down left eh
okay uh uh uh wait come on man that now
I know what to do this [ __ ] again why is
this guy's so hard okay come on we gotta
do this one again we got out of this one
hand finisher okay left okay left down
left eh there we go I got it look that
button work son
oh oh oh oh no no oh oh oh it's not even
over oh wow Wow oh you go crush your
skull with a big skull
he's just go here's the biggest goal
tale mmm oh my god dude oh wait you know
what I've seen
[Music]
oh my god that's nasty
I need to move me over a little bit huh
little ATC is covering me up senator
okay all right Joe
all right so that was Kotal Kahn serious
gear this is gonna beat up Kotal Kahn
there we go y'all
whoo how are we going where should we go
call a seal beast call us see a beast
pen okay here we go
finish him all right left downtown eh
oh oh oh [ __ ] ouch man oh he's still
alive oh that's not bad that one wasn't
as bad well he is punching the Jews
brain out the back of his head but that
wasn't as bad all right here we go
all right the collector
[Music]
Girish viewers all right call a seal
beast you pushed a to his brain out the
back of his head through the front and
his forehead came off oh this guy looks
nasty
down down down B oh man I [ __ ] that up
oh no he put the dude in his backpack
uh-oh this was gonna be nasty
he put the dude in his backpack oh Jesus
Christ
Penda Sherman okay down down down down
be oh oh this is gonna be nasty okay
oh oh no just ripping him apart
oh he's ripping him oh no it's hard he
looked at it oh not his head oh no oh
that's nasty he put his head he took his
head oh no when he looked at the heart
that was the [ __ ] up part what
happened was nasty
[Applause]
okay here we go guys
no well he has to collect her you right
he's the collector so he collect [ __ ] I
like how he looked at the heart doll he
was like smashing on him plane ticket
list hit [ __ ] out of here
sorry on again she got to beat up the
collector dude
alright here we go call a seal beast
just the last one
[Music]
hope this was worth it finish him okay
ba-ba-ba-ba
oh I [ __ ] it up
oh she's like what's that DC character
poison ivy yeah she looked like poison
ivy I thought I did that right that's
kind of stupid I did that right
this is practice mode alright alright
okay here we go
finish him alright so back down back
down B oh there it is
let's ooh she's got okay
oh she all she burned off his legs man
oh no no oh damn that was nasty are you
gonna burn him [ __ ] legs off
and then chop him into three oh man oh
man that was nasty oh man that was nasty
nasty nasty okay that's all of them guys
I think I did it I did them all I did
them all you know what this is a short
and sweet video I just wanted to do all
the fatalities so I'm gonna keep
practicing this game and see where we
going I'm still playing secure Row 2 I
got past a horse guy now I can't get
past this guy with the long-ass pole I
haven't got past his punk ass yet so I'm
still working on that but please hit the
subscribe button subscribe share like
also listen this is Griffin gaming but
it's everything's on-air Griffin comedy
Griffin with Griffin my podcast you know
so take a look at that playlist riff
from with Griffin and I really enjoyed
it you guys are watching my videos I
appreciate you so please share and like
I really appreciate it
alright and thank you for viewing
another episode of Griffin